take on e4 and allow let's just point
that out that after Knight C5 the idea
is not to take on e4 uh because then
don't forget that Queen from F7 will
jump onto A2 giving activities so Queen
E4 doesn't matter Queen G4 doesn't
matter you never take that Bishop where
do you go with your queen after Bishop
E4 Knight C5 and has King B had been
played is this no he's just gone Queen
F1 directly so he's threatening B Tech
C6 uh Shaq just wants to get in with his
Queen and Checkmate the black king
I think his focus is quite clear he's
not he's not transforming the position
into a strategic Advantage now now I
think he'll just take with the look yeah
he's taken with the Rook black has to
play Rook D7 and maybe something like
Rook C6 here Magnus hasn't assigned
Magnus has resigned he almost had a
little smile on his face at just how
miserable the position was he knows that
something went wrong but we've often
seen this from Magnus he has these shaky
starts in this tournament in these
tournaments but then go straight back to
bounce back into it so